[Music]  this home is about to become greener  thanks to newly installed insulation  for its owners the work was an economic  and environmental necessity  when  buildings account for about one-third of  eu greenhouse gas emissions  but making them more energy efficient  comes at a cost  this work was paid for in part by a  french government green home scheme  uh  now europe wants to go further with the  social climate fund  it's aimed at helping citizens small  businesses and road transport users  switch to clean energy  parliament is fighting for a deal based  on social justice  energy poverty has never been more  relevant than it is today we need a  clear definition to ensure funds are  targeted to those that most need it at  the heart of the social climate fund is  the need to ensure  that nobody is left behind in the green  transition  the social climate fund is part of  european green deal legislation aimed at  achieving carbon neutrality by 2050